Allahbar
[Silence]
on
Allah.
I don't know.
All
[Silence]
I saw. Oh,
I But Ib.
[Silence]
B.
Alhamdulillah.
Glory and
[Silence]
for
Well,ch. Wasam
[Silence]
Allah Subhanahu Waaala
All subal.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
in various places throughout the Quran
reminds us of one of the most decisive
and
most important blessings
that he has ever bestowed upon any
prophet and his followers.
He subhanahu wa ta'ala reminds us of the
victory that he bestowed upon upon our
prophet Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam
and his companions on the day of the
battle of Badr.
It is referred to as the battle of Badr
because of the place that it took of
where it took place. The battle took
place at an area
between Mecca and Medina referred to as
bad.
And here Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
gave victory to the prophet Muhammad
Sam. Wasam and his companions
in a victory
that had it been any other way, we would
not be here today discussing this. Islam
would not have reached us in the way
that it has
and history would have been radically
different than it is today.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala commanded his
prophet Sam
to migrate from Mecca to Medina 13 years
after he had first received the message
of Islam
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala commanded
him there to start the state of Islam
a knew
amongst
a fresh group of people who would later
be referred to as als
Als the victors, the ones who gave
victory to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam and opened their doors, opened
their city, opened their hearts to their
brothers, the migrants that came from
all over the Arab peninsula at the time.
And so
as this state was growing
in the second year
and they had barely arrived at Medina
for a little under two years
in Ramadan of the second year after
Hijra.
Our prophet sallall.aii
Wasallam
and a small band of his companions
had their first major and decisive
battle
between themselves and their antagonist
from amongst
in the area of Badr.
This was in the month of Ramadan
in the second year after hijra.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala reminds them
of this incredible blessing
that he subhanahua
gave them victory in spite of the
circumstances being against them.
All of the circumstances were against
them that day. All of them. Even the
ground underneath their feet.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
[Silence]
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam
was in Medina and he received word
that there was a caravan headed by Abu
Sufyan who was not Muslim at the time
headed by Abu Sufyan
headed back to Quray and it was only
guarded by about 30 men
and that this caravan would be very
lucrative for the Muslim
and a great blow go against
their
sworn enemy from amongst
and the people of Mecca
and they were at war.
They had both declared war against each
other, the Muslim and their antagonist.
And so the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam prepared very quickly,
very passively
to go and intercept this caravan.
He announced and only those from amongst
from
the were available at that time and
heard the call
and many of the muajir.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam along with 300 and roughly 15
of his companions from the muajir and
with very light weaponry. Remember they
were not going for war. They were not
going to a battle.
The companions
and the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam. They were going to intercept a
caravan.
This was supposed to be very quick work
to go arrive and come back within a day
or two.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii Wasam
set out with about 315
of his companions and they only had two
or three horse riders amongst them.
A horse back then is a tank for us
today. This was a big deal. Having a
horse, having
a knight who was mounted on a horse
during a battle. This is very important
back then. The Muslim, as Allah
described them,
they were in a state of poverty.
They were brushing shoulders with famine
and death at the time. And so they were
in desperate need of the gold and silver
and merchandise and wealth that was with
this caravan. They were in desperate
need of it and they could not afford a
full-on battle or war.
But Abu Sufyan received word
and so he sent
word back to
that Muhammad and his companions are
coming to intercept your money.
So bring a thousand men and let's crush
them once and for all.
And Abu Sophen
banked a hard right
until he reached the shores of the Red
Sea.
And when the prophet sallallah.aii Wasam
arrived at Badr.
He didn't find Abu Sufyan in a caravan
of gold and silver.
He didn't find a financial release for
the suffering Muslims.
He found a thousandman army
in their armor
with their weapons.
at Calvary
ready to fight.
And so now they're at a standoff.
You can't just turn around and run away
when something this occurs.
They're outnumbered.
They don't have the same artillery or
weapons.
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
asked the companions
home.
If you all want to go back, we can. We
didn't come for war.
And they said,
[Silence]
They said, "Oh messenger of Allah, we
are not going to say
what Benu is said to M on the gates of
Palestine
when they said, "You and your God, go
and fight and we'll wait right here for
you."
We learned that lesson.
If you want to shake the sea itself, we
are going to head into it and wage war
against the ocean with you.
We're here.
And they all unanimously chose to go
ahead and fight.
And so the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
spent that entire night in salah and
dua.
And he said
in his dua,
"Oh Allah, if you allow them to crush
this small band of believers,
you will not be worshiped again in the
earth properly.
These are the best of men
and the strongest of believers
and they were in a very very unopportune
position.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
had made it that
when the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam arrived
at Badr and they were waiting for him
that
there were very two t very two
distinguished types of ground underneath
the feet of the combatants.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam and his
companions were on a closer
place to Medina.
And the the soil underneath their feet
was very very loose,
very very bad for fighting on.
And the mushri, they were on nice
hard ground.
very tight soil under their feet. And so
it seemed everything was going
against them.
It seemed everything that could
possibly go wrong, even the ground
underneath their feet, was going wrong.
But then at night,
a couple of hours before the battle,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sent a
sleepiness upon the Muslim,
upon the prophet sallall.aii Wasam and
his companions.
And he sent a light mist of rain upon
them
and it just
bathed them
and
it
drove tranquility into their hearts.
Imagine they're about to
basically it's three to one.
With the weapons and with the
circumstances the way they are, it might
as well be 100 to one.
And
in about an hour, they are going to
what appears to be crushed by all of
their enemies.
And the mushrien were not going to stop
right there at Buddha. They were going
to start there and continue on to Medina
until every last Muslim was put to
death. The companions, they understood
this, but somehow
they were able to fall asleep not an
hour before their battle.
This sleep was a preparation from Allah.
He sent a light mist of rain upon them.
And this light mist, it turned the
ground that was loose gravel under their
feet. It turned it into a hard clay like
standing on stone.
And upon the mushrien, he sent a hard
rain
that turned that nice hard soil under
their feet into mud to their ankles.
And he kept them awake
and he kept fear in their hearts. And as
the two armies looked at each other just
before the battle and they were within
eyesight of each other,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
showed
the Muslim
to be very few in numbers, even less
than 300. The Mushri were looking at the
Muslim and they looked about 50
men.
And the Muslim were looking at
Abu Jah
and
Ib and Ib
and all of these antagonists from Mecca.
And they look to be very few.
And this is that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala allowed this illusion so that the
armies would collide and no no one would
turn back.
And
when the battle began,
Allah Subhanahu Waaala
immediately
made the Muslim seem to be twice the
size and amount of the mushri
and Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
changed even the ground and the sky
above and below the Muslim
And he sent a band of a thousand angels
to fight with the Muslim.
And within a few minutes,
the Muslim had totally
pulverized
their enemies from amongst the Mushri of
Quraysh.
They took 70 prisoners of war.
All of the major antagonists
from amongst the mushri were defeated
and the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
remained there at Badr for three days
and their nights.
And from that moment forth
the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
and his companions
rarely had to truly fight
because
most of their enemies were shaken to
their core by the mere thought
of the Muslim men coming to face them in
battle.
Because now it was known that the Muslim
are a new force on the playing field.
That the Arab Peninsula
has a new state, a united front, a
people that say
they're a people of justice, but they
are not a people to be trifled with or
crossed.
And Allah Subhanahu Waaala gave the
prophet sallall.aii
one of the most important
miracles that he had ever given any
prophet or messenger.
And Muslim
narrates that the prophet Sam
said,
he said, I have been given five things
that no prophet or messenger has ever
been given before me. And one of those
five things is I have been given victory
over my enemies with pure fear. A
distance of one month's travel from
wherever I am.
And so from that moment on, they were so
feared by their enemies
that
sometimes their enemies,
those who insisted
upon shik, those who insisted on
standing
between the Muslim and the people and
calling them to Islam, those who
insisted did
on going against the grain. They would
be so afraid of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam and his companions that they
would arrive at the battlefield a day or
two early and individually chain
themselves to the ground
just so they wouldn't run away when the
Muslim came. Some of them would actually
bring all their wives and children and
place them behind the mil the army just
so they wouldn't run away as an
incentive and they would still run away.
And the prophet sallallah.aii Wasam
said
that we have been chosen from amongst
Allah
to bring the people into paradise even
as they're kicking and screaming in
chains
in spite of themselves.
And this was a great miracle from Allah
and a mercy to mankind
that the Muslim
were now known as the
force of Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
So much so that the previous
prophets and messengers
when their people would reject their
message and attempt to kill them, Allah
would spare them and he would destroy
their people with some kind of calamity,
earthquakes or wind or
meteor showers or what have you.
But the punishment of Allah would be
separate for this for Muhammad and
his companions saiam
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala used him and
his companions themselves
as his sword of justice on this earth
and
subalu.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Islamus.
Allah.
for
[Silence]
either
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Allahb
stand shouldertosh shoulder close all of
the gaps as we mentioned before the
please stick around after the salah we
will have our fundraising our only
annual fundraising for academy the
school which is internally funded
privately funded so We would ask that
everyone inshallah
stick around after the salah for a few
minutes and help us to raise funds
inshallah for our children.
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
Holy
mean
[Silence]
Allah. Oh, I felt
[Arabic recitation]
allaykum. Assalamu alaykum.
for a few minutes and just you'll have a
tremendous reward for your time that you
spend with us inshallah. let me just
start by saying there's a 90 students at
the Rahma Academy. Alhamdulillah. And we
are doing extremely well. Alhamdulillah
from the TUSD standards and they are
trying every effort making every effort
to excel the programs.
We have 16 15 teachers and staff members
that are taking care of these children.
Without any further delay, I'd to
share with you that we have $660,000
budget of which most of it is covered
with the funds and donation and the the
grants and the dees programs and ES EFS
programs. It's about $100,000 that we
are short in the budget. So that's what
we are expecting or requesting you to
help us with. So without any further
delay, can I request for somebody to
raise their hand for $10,000?
Brother Raman Takb
one more time.
Brothers and sisters, how about the
second one?
10,000. Now if you really look at these
numbers, they are $833
a month if you spread it over the year.
So the number sounds big but if you
distribute it inshallah that would not
be so difficult and if you make the
pledge inshallah Allah will help you
achieve that goal by providing
additional funds inshallah. So it's our
Muslims belief that whatever we spend it
is replenished without any
shortcomings. So how about another
$10,000
Anybody?
I'll pledge 10,000 myself.
[Arabic recitation]
5,000.
That's only $400 some dollars a month.
400. Takir, you have a brother here.
Another one. Takir. Dr. Imran Takir. We
have somebody else.
5,000. That's only $430 a month.
Brothers and sisters, Takir for the
Shamshad there.
Anybody else on this side? Yeah,
[Arabic recitation]
to appeal to you at least to
encourage us by raising some hands,
inshallah.
Anybody?
$5,000.
How about f just $200 a month? That's
$2,500. Brothers and sisters, this is
something that really need to take care
of. This is not that's not going to go
away. It's just something that we going
to we can delay it but it has to be
taken care of for the sake of the the
children. Tak Dr. Nafi back there 2500
tak
another one 2500. We need at least five
more. 2500 brother Nadim Takir.
Anybody else on this side here? Takir.
Mashallah. Takir.
Another 2500.
Brothers and sisters, again a reminder
this is something that you will not even
miss this money. This is if you do a 12
payments that is not as big as it looks
like. $200 a month is something that
most of us can afford if we give up a
Starbucks coffee for instance.
So, $200 a month. That's all I'm asking.
Any hands?
How about 100? $1,000.
We should see some takir. You got a
brother here. Somebody else raise the
hand, please.
Brother Hamid Abaji. Takmir.
Another hand.
Brothers and sisters.
I would I would to ask you
three. Yeah. Takir
Dr. Rihan.
Brothers and sisters, this is I'm not
going to stop here. All I'm going to say
is I know some of you would to make
the you know donate without letting
anybody know and that is admirable and
alhamdulillah we just warm both people
are encouraging each other and also
people helping silently without
letting it the the second hand know
that. So really appreciate everything
you can do. Donation box is back there.
Even a dollar makes a difference.
Brothers and sisters, if you ever have a
question about Rama Academy and its
effects on our children, please I I
encourage you to come here to the school
in the morning during the morning
assembly and just watch these angels
recite and make dua for you and the
families. So that was really truly
remarkable. We do need the school to
flourish, Muslim schools to flourish to
save our children in this community.
Now again the box is there even a
dollar will help us tremendously.
another just announcement the fudger
prayer starting tomorrow morning is
going to be at 6:00 a.m. Fudgerama will
be at 6:00 a.m. inshallah.